- He's smoking.
They're smoking already.
There's a cat smoking!
- Everyone is smoking.
(playful Russian music)
- I don't speak Russian so I don't know
how much I'm gonna be able to understand.
- I think we're gonna be scolded a lot.
- I'm hoping there'll
be a lot of dark humor.
- Looks like it took a lot more effort
than some of the cartoons
I watched growing up.
- I don't know whether it's day or night.
- I feel like it's about
this guy being sad and lonely
looking for friends.
- His face looks so sad and miserable.
- There's a darkness there.
- [Both] Woah!
- What is that dinosaur!?
- Is he sad?
Or is he happy?
- It's like he's getting served
divorce papers or something.
- Oh my god look at that little guy.
- He would be cute in the daytime
and really freaky at night.
- Everyone is smoking!
- Why is everyone smoking
and why are the cigarettes backwards?
Is that how Russian people smoke?
- [Guy] Oh my god.
- That's like super hardcore.
- I don't trust that wolf.
- I feel like the wolf is the bad guy.
- So this is the healthy guy.
He's not smoking.
He's riding a bike.
- I think he's gonna eat the bunny.
- This seems like very Looney Tunesesque
to me.
- [Girl] Yes.
- I think it probably
is more inappropriate
for today's audience.
- He's so cute!
- He doesn't have legs but he has feet.
- Looks like this.
- Yeah, like a little chipmunk.
- It's kinda like a weird acid trip?
- It's like a children's
book but animated.
- I can't think of an American cartoon
that really looks like this.
- This is the most graceful fall.
- I bet Russian people loved it in 1965.
- I love it in 2016.
- He kind of reminded
me of Winnie the Pooh.
- Is it Winnie the Pooh?
- [Voiceover] It is, yeah.
Oh my god.
- Ohh.
- [Girl] Yeah.
- I'm just impressed with like
the quality of this.
- This looks like a video game.
- I'm worried about those animals' safety.
- This girl has a very
short attention span,
but also she's a child.
- She seems like a terror.
- Someone needs to teach her
how to properly play with animals.
- He's going into the forest.
- Oh, the bear has his own home.
- He's an artisanal bear.
- This bear's classier than me.
- Yeah, that's true.
- [Girl] Look at him drinking tea.
- She hasn't learned yet how to treat
other living beings.
- She's gonna come across
that bear and I think
he's gonna teach her some life lessons.
- I honestly wish our
cartoons were like this.
This is so cool.
- I'm like really impressed with just
how the cartoons look,
like the animations.
- I might binge watch it.
- You would binge watch this?
- [Guy] I would binge watch this.
- I think they're like way
cooler than American cartoons.
(air swishing and metal squeaking)